>> The question being asked here today is
can India become a superpower?
I think we need to ask ourselves first, what
is a superpower?
Can India grow in economic size?
Of course, it will grow.
I mean, I think that's pretty obvious right
now.
Can India be a leader in the region?
To some extent it already is and will get
bigger in the future.
Can India grow militarily?
I guess we already have a large-sized military
which is considered one
of the finer ones in the region and many say
in the world.
So what we have to address is the challenge
of poverty that still
plagues us since Independence.
If we can address the needs of education and
health care of 215
million people in India, and many of them
don't get two square meals a
day, I think India's well on its way to becoming
a leading nation of
the world in many different ways.
We have enterprise, we have innovation, we
have people who want to live
with diversity.
We have extreme diversity as a nation, and
that is strengthening the
nation, actually strengthens India.
In fact, that's a lesson that many in of other
parts of the world can
learn as well.
And our diversity in many ways is something
which will help India cope
with not just the current, but we hope also
in the future and build it
into a leading nation, as many of believe
it should be.